breaking news mcdonald's is now entering
the metaverse mcdonald's has filed for
patents and trademarks and all sorts of
other legal documentation saying that
mcdonald's is going to bring a virtual
cafe to a virtual world near you
mcdonald's filing for this new trademark
that indicates they plan to offer
virtual restaurants featuring actual and
virtual goods and operating a virtual
restaurant featuring home delivery now
for those of you paying attention at
home when we think of virtual
restaurants in the metaverse we think of
them obviously only being able to sell
and provide virtual goods your little
avatar can go get fat on diet coke on
salty fries and on big macs that's how
mcdonald's gets down but if they're
talking about actual virtual restaurants
that would serve real food what they
seem to be doing is not only talking
about virtual restaurants in the
metaverse but also the ability to have
things like ghost kitchens mcdonald's
realizing that maybe people don't want
to simply just go sit at mcdonald's
where the flurry machines are broken and
as they sit there realize that i'm
eating shitty food i'm getting unhealthy
so mcdonald's trying to stay ahead of
the curve i love mcdonald's just as much
as anybody but if they are going to be
the leading fast food joint in the
future they're going to have to continue
to innovate and that innovation
obviously things like ghost kitchens is
a possibility changing the unit
economics makes it a better business for
them but what is even crazier and even
more exciting is that if mcdonald's is
able to take over the metaverse then
mcdonald's will ultimately be able to be
the choice of the next generation in
virtual goods imagine if all of a sudden
as you were running through playing a
video game or you simply were going to
meet up with friends maybe you're going
to go meet zuck at facebook work or any
of their other virtual works that
they've created you could simply chow
down on a virtual big mac now some of
this is ridiculous some of this
obviously is not going to come to
reality but to see that mcdonald's is
thinking about this is just another sign
that the metaverse is the topic du jour
inside of these corporate boardrooms i
would love to see the executive team at
mcdonald's sitting there talking about
we should build a virtual restaurant in
the metaverse and somebody's saying do
you want to actually have virtual
ketchup and mustard or are we simply
going to pretend and not have to worry
about ingredients that's the type of
[ __ ] that's going inside of these
corporations when you guys think about
this
do you think that they're literally
gonna actually like
have virtual restaurants in the
metaverse john you just watch ready
player one like what if there's just
mcdonald's everywhere i can definitely
see that i think it's a massive there's
gonna be tons of advertisements in the
metaverse as well which i don't think
people really utilize um or really think
about at least but yeah there's gonna be
mcdonald's you're gonna see the golden
arches in the metaverse for sure
yeah i think so why not i mean look if
people are spending the majority of
their time in in a decade now within
these virtual worlds right whether
you're at you know home or doing
something else why wouldn't you want to
have a presence there if you're a major
brand that can do it right so like
they're the the large quick service
restaurant uh brand in the world they
have 40 000 restaurants i was just
looking up three of them are opening up
per day
and uh i think it's no-brainer for them
to have a presence within the metaverse
or the virtual world or whatever you
want to call